weird duh mob you're not dumb in any way
you are actually quite smart now your
God voice there are bookshelves and the
books early Oh God there you know you
use the mail Bob I'm going my way no I
just this is a nightmare
ooh this gonna be really freaking hard
considering that I have absolutely zero
knowledge of this map I don't know what
you mean by nice sex fact quite
delightful oh my god there's a strip
club in here
computers are called beefy computers
really so you're in a computer room huh
you're in a room with a computer huh
yeah is that a room you know don't make
flat room Wow here oh okay does anyone
see what I got I don't know what that
means no I just wanna speak up to the
effect that I am going to do something
I'm not saying a word
does anybody have any qualms by with
which they want to speak up I am NOT
saying a word just hey there's a movie
theater in here awesome this is a really
nice house oh yeah super nice there's a
black weird watermelon over here I'm a
Barbie girl whoa jeez god no sorry hey
Bob you gotta look at what I got though
where are you I'm coming back downstairs
I'm coming downstairs look at my new toy
Bob Oh God so so where is everyone
however she doesn't figure out yeah we
don't quite know the map yet but this
Bob this is you know this is only fair
how do you know where zombies I don't
know but I'm right here you're right
bear oh yeah they're into this table
[Laughter]
zombi that is amazing that's take all
you guys you're never gonna stop me I'm
gonna kill you I'm hot oh no no I was
gonna come here wait no we could both do
it
Oh God okay okay okay I'm gonna stop
moving toward me okay you are facing the
wrong way you're facing 90 degrees to
the right of where do you think you're
facing Oh God
here let me see if I can oh that's bad
you're screwed see okay I'm okay I'll be
okay you are a jerk a jerkwad with jerk
consistencies and you are an a-hole I
told you you were no good I had no
choice at that point Bob you're gonna
die oh thanks no I don't know where you
think he is but you're shooting one of
these machines here and it's not hurting
us yeah well how do I look
oh you you got a lot of bullet holes but
you look great otherwise perfectly
aligned Bob do you real you is facing
the wrong direction so I should do this
oh you two are such morons oh you're
such morons
you guys aren't actually in the same
room no you can become that I didn't
either
[Laughter]
interesting housing choice made it's
very strange oh this is scary this is my
life now this is
yes so far you so good I mean the two
morons over there just being morons I
think you're gonna be fine where are you
oh that is good
how's that that is good Bob you look
good it's a little twitchy but they
think you're good how's that still
switch it but you're fine you're fine
you're fine about this oh I'm inside and
I'm upstairs I'm done mess of this room
I can't it's beautiful yeah all right so
there's a bunch of stuff in the room
that I'm in this all thrown around and
you might think of it I may have been an
umbrella at some point or or a chair or
a table or I know there's stuff this is
just like skewed about like crazy like
some [ __ ] was in here messing around
oh no no no no oh no no no uh-huh
oh wow no bad should I should I run out
the door right now mark no I think
you're good I think you're golden from
here on out I think you're fine what cuz
you said you know what you really should
do is you should look in the bathroom
some zombie uh wait maybe you should
have a drink Wow even see you move if
you need any I've got some stuff I could
share with you or or not share his left
Wow Bob okay cards on the table I've
been watching a lot of seananners videos
and I have some new ideas about to play
this game they were whaling on this
vending machine for like the other one
hurt us and then the other one did we we
were both gonna do that and then I was
all yeah that's a horrible idea it was
like
Bailon I'm out of here hey Bob can you
cover the entrance to the house I'm
gonna make a loop outside and see if I
see pens I'm watching it inconspicuous
all right there they want entrance to
the house I'm pretty sure Bob watching
the entrance I'm chasing a bottle right
now to be make an ass out of himself
hang on let me get let me get the head
of you heavy ordnance down there waiting
let me get this entrance to the basement
yes I over there I'm watching okay I got
I got it covered
where is he oh here you going I'll stay
out here where is he he was at the
height I was a little brown bottle right
I have an idea I have these two where'd
you end up going mark oh I know did you
go inside
what the hell you should do some pole
dancing mark I should I really should
[Laughter]
feeding or something right away what
were you I was a box out on the pier but
I perfectly destroyed the other box and
replaced it exactly ish
Chiti Chiti we were talking about
negligence the elements of negligence
because I'm in law school and and one of
the elements of negligence is that there
has to be a duty on the party that is
being accused of being negligent and not
that important but we were discussing it
and at some point my professor started
to use a buckets
metaphor and she said Duty bucket while
she was addressing me I actually laughed
in her face talk about filling up
metaphorical buckets and she just looks
at me and she goes mr. Baskins the the
duty bucket and I literally went yeah I
would have bust out laughing more than
that so uh you can become an egg in the
kitchen
hi hi there
hey Bob watch this door for me I'm gonna
go ahead yeah hello someone uh someone
in here someone someone closed the door
give us some privacy in here give you
guys a minute no one in here
someone ah I see you back here shooting
back back back there we go I got him no
stupid shotgun kid the shotgun oh
awesome while I'm still active he's in
the kitchen I couldn't even tell
[Music]